hello and welcome to sue and playing
contrast what am I going for them I want
to do something else let's play the
check-rein Tony and see if I can get
something going on the kingside later
yeah people know that line by now okay
yeah each voice is good okay maybe I can
play for b5 break and that gets a little
bit more likely with the light square
Bishop strated yeah dried form at be
five so let's castle and see if I can
get that in
hey five was interesting for wipe it we
played ping g2 very quickly what is he
shooting for you f4 maybe I go Knight g4
okay so i can go be five now right it
takes a couple of times takes eight at
the end I should get b5 back so yeah
also I got a little bit carried away
here playing as quickly as he does it's
not a good idea Chad not sure that
something bad is happening but I should
have yeah I should have taken a moment
and really quick and really consider
what wide was force was up to ok I'm
going to be seven maybe
rook is annoying
I is out for possible at 4am that's
indeed a bit of a problem I cannot move
the king at the moment okay maybe start
with this may have to go back to a one I
guess or a two and then we'll see okay
yeah I don't mind that trading stuff is
certainly good for me I mean not good in
terms no not good as in being better but
I don't mind peace treaty of course
it takes its open the very equal ish
Green says success may be interesting oh
okay
okay well you should have six maybe
hmm interesting is that good for white
if i do if i go f6 there many can can
can we might come around there to see
seven but i can take a five right why
not i can take a five to pick up to five
yeah it's not exactly the dream outcome
from white I wonder if he can go King
King III king of 395 kingi for maybe
much totally sure about the king of porn
ending and it could could well be a draw
now so i probably have to move the night
to c7
might be six maybe also push it in five
mins sd5 check yeah that's not so easy
actually from a technical point of view
now yes so try Bishop f5 otherwise I
play f6 and t5 and then then it simply
over I guess yeah d5 checking you five
nights see for checking d 595 king c5 my
night has huge problems them it's not
not easy not easy at all
I think this is better to be honest and
that move I didn't see at all okay of
six then what's the point
ok so i take him and then i have to get
tried to win divine wants them cannot go
d5 I have to check on the to it it
doesn't help ok I'm grabbing this I
cannot actually take him there
to get the night around
Andy his Kings nicely nicely shielded
I'd like to go to the six samurai need
to ultimately win the pawns but i don't
know if i can get down check
don't see how I cannot take it spawns
these six is the right square but I
don't see how to get down let's go
forward okay it's such a relief
can take just reality easier check
check Wow dirty trick CM check check
check check check white forfeits on time
okay I got eight seconds at the end go
ahead got home or far trickier that
ain't even a thought um yeah he
definitely had a better position but he
traded too much and trade it too much
this was surprising already my trade to
active rook well and TM I think if he go
he has to go Randall Queen a six or
queen Queen c6 was also interesting and
just keep the tension there yeah the
Queen has invaded it's a better piece in
my queen and trading I think after that
I should be okay and here we have to be
careful this is this is just a mistake
I'm I'm winning this now and yeah okay
the computers giving this this is maybe
even stronger now it is stronger chantix
Teague's here then I can come around
get-get Knight f6 and at the end it's
even easier than this and hear things
out the computer is just giving equal I
had this hunch during the game I
couldn't really see a way forward and
this and while King g5 no wins for white
amazing
whoa so that means f6 was a pretty awful
idea yeah this is the thing I kai he
invades here and he promotes haha whoa
that would have been half white just
wins Wow and after this I'm Winningham
no probably not very convincing from my
aunt nitey one is better I had also
shielding the King yeah so hmm now this
is this is coming yeah that's a pretty
clear winner I'm actually forcing with
this what what I got in the game a
little bit later when I came around
there and now can pick up all the pawns
yeah that was a lucky win he had this
King be 5 is 6 after which who I would
have probably had some some curses
lineup okay thanks for watching